[Music]
welcome back everyone so today i'm going
to start a mini lecture series on
complex analysis
which is essentially the study of
numbers and functions
of complex variables z
where z has a real part and an imaginary
part we write this usually as x plus iy
x is real uh y is also real but i y is
imaginary
and
in my kind of
college math class this would usually
take up about two weeks the series i'm
about to to give you right now
uh i think i'm hoping to do this in
about 12 or 13 little mini lectures i'm
really hoping it ends up being 13.
the inauspicious and occasional number
of lunar
months that fit into a solar year
okay so
complex
functions and complex variables come up
all the time in differential equations
ordinary differential equations
odes
like
when we deal with pendulum swinging
or if we have a
a mass on a spring
that is oscillating pretty much anything
in physics that oscillates that moves
back and forth
is going to involve some kind of complex
function
usually we think of this motion as
periodic so it's going to be described
by sines and cosines and what we're
going to see very very quickly is that
sines and cosines are actually the
imaginary and real parts of a complex
exponential function so very cool stuff
um
good
now when um
when i start i like to to kind of define
what i mean by i this imaginary number
most of you know this from you know from
high school or grade school you've seen
this before we say that uh
you know i equals or is defined as the
square root of negative one
so we know what the square root of nine
is it's it's you know three but it could
also be minus 3 because minus 3 times
minus 3 is positive 9.
and very quickly uh in school you
realize that these negative numbers
don't have
a real valued square root there's no
real number that when squared will give
you a negative number and so you have to
introduce this imaginary this this i
this other variable i that is defined as
the number that when squared equals
negative one
this has bothered
humans for centuries um all the way back
in the 1500s actually i think all the
way back to alexandria it was recognized
that you needed other numbers
uh
to take these square roots but
especially in the 15 16 and 1700s lots
of mathematicians
really wrestled with what this meant
they didn't like this number
descartes called this imaginary in kind
of a derogatory way and it wasn't until
euler and gauss
you know a bit later that this really
started to become an established part of
mathematics and if you think about it
you know even negative numbers for a
long time were not really seen as real i
could of course owe someone you know
five apples which is kind of like
negative five apples but you know the
idea of multiplying two negative numbers
and getting a positive number is still
kind of unintuitive for for kids you
need to get a lot of intuition and build
up a lot of experience of how numbers
work and how subtraction works before
you can make that leap and this is kind
of the same way
but i want to point out that this is
very much not an imaginary number in my
mind these are extremely concrete
quantities again that are everywhere in
our solution to ordinary and partial
differential equations
so i'm going to walk you through bit by
bit piece by piece how to think of
complex variables how to think of
complex numbers and functions of these
complex variables and we're going to use
these over and over again in
differential equations you know to solve
the wave equation the heat equation
spring mass system things like that
now in the uh bronze age when when i
went to school
this whole series on complex analysis
would have been an entire you know
10-week class there is a huge amount of
depth
that you can study complex variables
in my class that i teach to my students
at university of washington i've
condensed this down to
one week of essential material
and then one week of kind of extra
advanced material that i think
most students should know it's almost
like you take
you know art and history classes uh so
that you have a well-rounded education
kind of a liberal arts education i
almost think of complex analysis that
second week as like a liberal science
education it's something that people
should know even if we don't use it as
much as we did 50 years ago okay
good so i'm going to keep going through
this so we're talking about these
complex numbers that have a real and an
imaginary part and we have defined this
imaginary number i as the number that
when squared equals negative one
so it is the solution
the solution to the polynomial equation
x squared
equals negative 1.
and again for a long time people realize
that there are polynomials you can write
down that don't have real valued
solutions okay this bothered people for
hundreds of years there's actually a
great veritasium video on the history of
the imaginary number i'll put a link
in the in the description below
but it was recognized at some point down
the line
i'm guessing probably gauss formalized
this
that
you need these imaginary numbers to to
write down the solution of a generic
polynomial so if you have any polynomial
i can write down its solution
the roots of that polynomial will
generically need complex
valued numbers to express those roots
for example this is a polynomial where x
has to equal
i or minus i
to satisfy this polynomial
okay and so in some sense that means
that these imaginary numbers are
necessary so if we want all of the
solutions of these polynomials
uh then we need these imaginary these
complex numbers to represent these
solutions
and it wasn't until quite some time that
people also proved that these are
sufficient i can write down any
polynomial any any real coefficient
polynomial
and i can represent all of the solutions
in this form
so that means that there i don't need
some other variable plus j z where j is
some other quantity to represent the
solutions a real and an imaginary valued
number like this
is sufficiently rich enough to capture
the solution of all polynomials and in
fact that's even true if i had complex
coefficients on these polynomials if i
had i times x squared equals negative
one that would also have roots that are
uh representable by complex numbers
so that's kind of an interesting and
important mathematical fact that these
numbers are are are necessary to
represent the roots of polynomials but
they are also sufficient uh they are
rich in us enough class of numbers uh we
would say that the the solutions of
these polynomials are closed under under
the complex numbers
okay good so we know that these uh come
up all the time in ordinary and partial
differential equations uh things like
this also write down that these are
important in partial differential
equations things like
uh the wave equation so if we have you
know the
the motion of a guitar string this is
going to be written in terms of sines
and cosines and oscillating quantities
we're going to need complex functions
the heat equation this comes up all the
time in the heat equation again the
fourier decomposition that we use to
solve the heat equation is naturally
written in terms of complex variables
this comes up in fluid dynamics so
potential flows it comes up in quantum
so the schrodinger
quantum
the schrodinger equation natively has is
a complex
valued
uh is a partial differential equation in
terms of a complex valued wave function
electromagnetism the
electric and magnetic fields can be
thought of as the real and imaginary
components of a complex function
so really
these are not imaginary at all they come
up all the time in the physical world
now part of the reason this is so
confusing and it has been it still is
and it has been for hundreds of years
is because even though when we write
down the mathematical solution of
ordinary and partial differential
equations we get complex valued
functions all the time everything we
have ever measured in the real world are
real valued i can only have a real
valued angle theta this can go from you
know minus pi to pi but it can't be i pi
same thing with the velocity of this
mass that is a real quantity in terms of
real meters per seconds and so that's
still
kind of one of the things that's a
little bit confusing is trying to really
disentangle how everything we ever
measure in the real world is real but
under the hood kind of in the the
mathematical representation of these
things we need complex numbers uh to
write them down
and i think a lot of this
can be understood in terms of this
complex exponential function i'm going
to come back to this over and over and
over again
this function e to the i theta
so euler's formula euler wrote this down
and it's one of the most important
formulas in all of math is e to the i
theta
can be written as cosine of theta
plus i
times
sine of theta
and so essentially e to the i theta for
a real valued or imaginary is let's say
for a real value
theta
this is a complex number that has a real
part given by cosine of theta and an
imaginary part given by sine of theta
and so all of these oscillating
quantities here
like this mass on a spring or this
oscillating pendulum
i could think about the position of this
pendulum or the position of this mass as
being given by the real part this cosine
of theta
and we know that the velocity of the
pendulum the theta dot or the you know y
dot
of these quantities are 90 degrees out
of phase those are the sine theta the
imaginary part of this function
and so again
everything we ever measure is written in
terms of these real numbers x and y
but those are the real and imaginary
part of a complex valued function okay
good so we're going to be covering this
again 12 or 13 lectures on this we're
going to get pretty deep into how to do
calculus with complex variables
numerical sorry differentiation and
integration we're going to talk about
special functions of complex variables z
but today i really want to get into you
know how do you actually manipulate
these quantities how do you do simple
things like addition subtraction
multiplication division
how do you write these imaginary these
complex numbers in polar coordinates
um
and you know and at the end i'll give
you kind of a road map of where we're
going to go with this short lecture
series
okay good
uh so i think at this point what i'm
going to do
is just go into you know basic basic
things like how do you do addition and
subtraction
so
let's just get started so addition
and subtraction
and i'm going to say um
let's say that we have you know z
1 equals
x 1 plus i y 1 and we're going to say
that z 2
equals x 2 plus i y
2. good
so addition subtraction if i have you
know z
1 plus or minus z
then that is going to equal
x1 plus or minus x2
plus i times y1 plus or minus y2
so if i add two complex numbers z1 plus
z2 the real parts add and the imaginary
parts add
and if i subtract two complex numbers z1
minus z2 then i subtract the real parts
x1 minus x2 and i subtract the imaginary
parts y1 minus y2 very very simple
if i do let's say multiplication
multiplication
i'll do multiplication and division
so multiplication this was addition
subtraction multiplication
would be
z1 times z2
and we're going to just multiply this
out so we have x1 plus iy1 times x2 plus
i y 2
and we know that that is going to equal
so just like in you know algebra class
you multiply every single
pairwise combination and add them up so
you get four terms x1 times x2 plus
x1 times iy2 plus iy1 times x2 plus iy1
times iy2
and we're going to collect all of the
real parts and all the imaginary parts
so i get x1 x2
that's a real number and i y1 times iy2
remember i squared is negative 1 so
that's just minus y1 times y2
so those are the two terms that are real
plus there will be two terms that are
imaginary and that is x1 times iy2
plus y1 times x2 so x2 y1 and those are
both imaginary
so this is uh how you do multiplication
with complex numbers
i'm going to show you that this is
actually way easier to do using the
polar uh coordinate representation of
these numbers
but i'll get to that in a second
uh let's say we do division
okay so division would be
let's say i take z1 divided by z2
so that's
x1 plus iy1
divided by x2 plus iy2
and again from your kind of high school
or middle school math class you probably
remember that if you want to get rid of
a complex number in the denominator you
multiply
on the top and the bottom by its complex
conjugate by
x to minus iy
to
x2 minus iy2
and when you do that
the term on the bottom becomes a real
number so if you expanded this all out
just like here
you would find that this equals on the
on the denominator this equals x squared
minus
i squared that's minus minus that's plus
y squared
and this is x2 and y2
and on the top i'm just going to say
that this is z1
times z2 complex conjugate
and we define complex conjugate by this
over bar i'll write this down in a
minute just so that you know what that
means
uh and so this is z1 z2 bar
over this quantity here is kind of the
length
or the the the size of this z2 the norm
of z2
quantity uh squared okay so now i'm
going to define what this means just
make a little note here
note
that
z bar equals x minus i y
is the complex
conjugate
and the length of a complex number z
is equal to kind of its radius which is
x squared plus y squared
square root okay good
good uh so now what we've seen
essentially is that we can do you know
all of the basic things we want to
basically be able to do algebra with
these complex numbers we can add we can
subtract we can multiply divide you can
multiply these by a constant you know 5
times z you just multiply 5x plus 5i
[Music]
and we did this in this kind of
cartesian coordinate system where you
have the real and the imaginary part
but it turns out it's actually
way way easier to do multiplication and
division if instead of writing it like
this you write these numbers in a polar
coordinate system so i'm just going to
do that really quickly i'm going to say
that this equals
instead of x plus iy we're going to say
that this equals some radius
maybe i'll derive this first okay this
is going to be some radius
times an e to the i theta i'll tell you
what this means in a minute but let's
actually just draw this here
so the idea is that any complex number
x plus iy
can be written in terms of the real part
of z
and the imaginary part of z and we can
put these on coordinate axes we can have
a real axis and an imaginary axis that
are kind of perpendicular to each other
this is called the complex plane and
usually i'll denote this by this kind of
script c
and any number z
that i want to represent any number z
that has a real part and an imaginary
part
essentially the real part
uh is its position in this x-axis
and the imaginary part is its position
on this y axis so x in the real
direction y in the i direction let's say
this is kind of the you know i direction
here
but of course i can also represent these
in terms of polar coordinates just like
you know and normally i can represent a
cartesian vector x plus x comma y i can
also represent this in terms of a radius
and an angle theta
so if i do that here i would say that
the radius is r
and the theta the angle is theta so i
can just as well represent this complex
number in terms of a radius and an angle
theta
and the way that we write that is r
times e to the i theta
and i'll explain why this is true in a
minute so
essentially if this is the angle theta
of z
then we know that this uh
position here this x
is
r cosine
theta
and this y direction is
r sine of theta
and remember from euler's formula
e to the i theta is cosine theta plus i
sine theta so i can write this
r cosine theta plus i times r sine theta
as r e to the i theta this is how we
write this
in complex polar form
now i'm going to derive this uh in the
next lecture so essentially what we're
going to do is we're going to take the
taylor series
the taylor series
for
uh e to the let's call it e to the z
and then we're going to plug in i theta
in for z and we're going to find that
all of the real parts add up to cosine
and all of the imaginary parts add up to
sine so just take my word for this right
now this is called euler's formula
again one of the most important formulas
in all of mathematics euler's euler's
formula
and this is we're using this kind of to
write down
this complex number in polar form
but what i really wanted to show you is
that complex multiplication
is particularly easy when we write it
down in polar form so let's do that
let's say
that again i have
a few vectors and i'm going to use
different colors for these
so let's say i have some vector
let's call this z1
and then i have another vector that is
let's say
z2
and i want to multiply these and i'm
going to say that z1 equals
r1 e to the i theta 1. so this is
theta 1 and its length is r1
and z2 is going to be
r2 e to the i
theta 2. so again the length of this
vector is r2 if that's its radius
in this you know if i had a circle that
would be the radius r2
and this has a angle theta
2.
now if i multiply
those two quantities maybe i'll do this
in blue here
so i take r
e to the i theta 1
times r 2 e to the i
theta 2
that is going to by just multiplication
be r1 r2
e to the i theta 1 plus theta
2.
and so this is i think what's really
really neat is that in polar coordinates
it's instead of multiplying this all out
and collecting the real and the
imaginary parts which gets to be kind of
a pain if i multiply two complex
variables that are already written in
polar coordinates then their radii
multiply r1 times r2 like the the new
vector that i'm going to get out of this
this is
let's say
z1 z2
the radius of this
is going to be r
1 times r2
so those multiply
and the angles the angle of z1 and the
angle of z2 just add so this uh
third angle here
is theta 1 plus theta 2. so this is e to
the i
theta 1 plus
theta 2.
and that's just a property of how
exponentials multiply if i multiply two
exponentials then the arguments just add
so e to the i theta 1 times e to the i
theta 2 is e to the i theta 1 plus theta
2.
so that's kind of nice okay so
multiplication and you could kind of
verify that this is also true of
division this is
if i wanted to divide these quantities
this would be r1 divided by r2
times e to the i
theta 1 minus theta 2 something like
that okay so it's way way easier to
multiply or divide when i think about my
complex numbers in this polar coordinate
system
and i mean this is also going to be true
when we do physics when we do ordinary
differential equations and partial
differential equations just like i
showed you down here
it's going to be very very natural
sometimes to think about
instead of writing things in real plus
imaginary part just to think about it in
terms of you know this kind of polar
form e to the i theta that's going to be
more useful when we think about the wave
equation when we think about oscillating
variables
in physics as well
okay good um
yeah so let me see what else do i want
to tell you um
maybe i'll tell you what's coming next
okay so
this is just the very very very basic
tip of the iceberg where we have talked
about why
we care about complex numbers they come
up all the time in any kind of
oscillating solution of ordinary or
partial differential equations
we've talked a little bit about what
these complex numbers are complex
numbers are the necessary
ingredients to the solution of
polynomials things like you know if i if
i want a square root of negative 1 i
have to introduce this i
we've talked a little bit about the how
how do we add how do we multiply how do
we divide
and specifically that it is easier
a lot of times to do this multiplication
and division when we use the polar form
uh this radius times e to the i theta
maybe i'll just write this out really
really really explicitly that
this you know z equals r e to the i
theta equals r times cosine theta
plus i sine
theta and again r cos theta is the real
part x and r sine theta is the imaginary
part y these are totally equivalent
representations of this complex number
and what's coming next
kind of the next piece of all of this
is
let's say next
we'll be thinking about
functions of a complex variable so
functions like what if i take you know z
quantity squared if i take this complex
number z squared
you can verify that this will equal
what is it going to equal x squared
minus y squared
plus i times 2xy that is a complex
function z squared
and you can write down lots and lots and
lots of interesting functions that are
going to be useful in the solution of
ordinary and partial differential
equations uh polynomials like z to the n
you can write down sine of z cosine of z
e to the z we've already seen e to the i
theta
so all of our favorite functions from
real analysis from real valued function
theory like sine and cosine and
exponential logarithm is a hugely
important one log of z
i give it a capital l to distinguish it
from the real value log of z
all of these can be extended to be
functions of a complex variable not just
a real variable x but a complex variable
z so this is just one
example here
and what we're going to find is that
there is a huge class of what are called
analytic
functions like z squared or z to the n
or e to the z sines and cosines these
are analytic functions
and what that means is that the real
part and the imaginary part this
function of x and y and this function of
x and y
are solutions
to laplace's equation to laplace's
equation uh deltron del squared of let's
say the real function phi equals zero
and this again is hugely important these
are the solutions uh the building blocks
of electromagnetism of the heat equation
of the wave equation of all of partial
differential equations much of partial
differential equations
is built on laplace's equation
and the solutions of laplace's equation
are the real and the imaginary part of
these
analytic complex functions
so this is all coming up in the next
let's say 12
or 13 lectures we're going to talk about
how to do calculus how to define
functions of complex variables how to do
calculus on those functions derivatives
and integrals
how to understand how these are
solutions of laplace's equation we're
going to derive euler's formula
for the taylor series
e to the you know of e to the i theta
and all of that so again this is about a
two week course the first week i would
say is essential to understanding how
complex variables work
the second week is interesting but
pretty advanced material so i highly
recommend the first part but if you're
interested
stick around for the whole thing all
right thank you